citizens of the reject Nation we are coming at
you today with Batman the long Halloween part
one neither of us have seen it as is tradition
true have read it have you read it I have read it
it's been a while in fact I think this would have
been an opening day of the Dark Knight waiting 12
plus hours in line with the paperback it is a
damn fine novel I'm very excited to dive into
the animated to see how it adapts itself please
do like comment subscribe hit that notification
Bell so you can see when part two pops up as well
as the rest of our dcau journey speaking of Batman
the Batman shirt is available from shop zero
edition.com and we are also going to be at
Comic-Con and if we see you wearing this shirt
we're gonna give you a nice crisp high five gonna
be very Adam Westy because it's gonna be more
loving than violent but we can promise you some
dancing uh we're gonna be there on Saturday early
afternoon we got tons of details to come very very
soon by the time you see this video but know that
if you're there Saturday early afternoon the real
rejects will also be there Marvel ran away from
us so you got time you're not gonna be standing
in the hall h line you're gonna be standing in
our line so we'll see you there at Comic-Con you
lovelies and speaking of excellent Vigilantes
I would like to thank all of the patrons for
joining us as ever if you want to watch this front
to back start to finish we want some resting faces
then you become a patron and you
can be super sexy like the rest
of them as we watch this in its entirety
without further Ado let's get Halloween
animatic very uh Batman series there we go there's
the ticket maybe it was just a silent intro it's
just luring you in with it deeper oh that's
gorgeous look at that establishing wow that
may be my favorite establishing shot today that
was stunning Gotham City [Music] I only came
here out of respect from my parents who knew
your family that is definitely a Jensen Ackles
Thomas Wayne believed in my father he believed
a man could bring order to a world of chaos he
also celebrated Halloween and you Bruce every
year they're doing a good job of the Jeff Loeb
writing but also the Tim sale art but not as
directly as the Frank Miller it's like shades
of it yeah Tim sale passed away last year and uh
one of the most formative Batman artists one of
those forms of comic artists of all time rest
in peace what uh what a Titan whoa thank you
scallops though
oh there it is already I can just feel
like the pace the tone feels different
seems like this will have a lot more breathing
room I love the art style the watercolor blend oh
there's my Tim sailor oh yeah well this is taking
me back this book has beautiful art it really does
oh rest in peace and like we saw the Frank
Miller that was like a direct adaptation
this is more like shades of because I don't
know if the Tim sale style would translate
to movement as linear because like this
just so striking in its pauses yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like it's made to be still
see yeah a little bit because I remember
the like Splash pages in this where you like
Turn the Page and you just stop [Music] whoa
come a long way from Red Hood boy this is
incredible I love this music too you're the
only person who probably feels a little cooler
than Batman right the only person that could
even comprehend what it's like to feel as cool
as Batman that was sick love it love it love it
oh that's right
nicely done how about the nipple silencer I
miss Kyle telephone she said she was checking
the number you gave her to make sure it's
real it's an absurd holiday oh yes putting
on costumes and striking fear quite absurd and
collecting candy do you really think that's how
it feels Bruce yeah Bruce just stole Alfred's
bit I mean many of them is am I six training
excited Jim cop ghost the specter Easter egg
when I'm on my way your father's captain now
the whole Department's counting on
him well I was counting on him too
oh Gilda there you are Harvey you home better late
than never the most built D.A do you have any kids
trick-or-treaters I don't think I'm really up for
all that tonight yeah I saw the ball on the porch
it's okay it's a ghost town out there there were
a lot of kids out from just now he's helping her
feel better but uh it's awesome I'm dedicated to
Halloween over anyone's feelings sit on that porch
you have to go pick a movie
I'll be back soon I love you
oh I love that it actually feels like a Halloween
movie like there's a spooky ethereal like kind of
yeah pervades the whole sort of ambiance yeah it
feels like I like want to watch this on Halloween
with lights off yeah maybe it'll be part of
the new uh every annual rotation yeah gentlemen
return you Harvey bats dead okay Johnny Beatty
was murdered tonight it's Carmine Falcone not
the right calm down where were your men Jim oh
hard to tell if we're dealing with a professional
of course it was a professional this was
Falcone he found out video so he took him
up praised the art in the photos he was
ready to sing not just about Carmine
the whole family was going away we had a real
opportunity to change things a complete Opera
it
who did Salvatore moroney if anyone is responsible
for my nephew's death it's that new son of a
[__] in the DA's office Sling Blade over here
yep just say the word come on and I'll do that
myself at the right time we'll hit back and the
right time is now Carmine no disrespect come on
ooh too late it's Godfather he looks like
Don corleo you see how we've drawn him
I mean that was a lot of difference oh buddy
oh damn thank you
as the elements and the sound design
the watercolored like background yeah
wait do you see what's inside oh this was
a work thing that we were flirting the only
thing that doesn't work with Jensen Ackles
is Batman is both of his voices sound too
cool you'd recognize him that's true he doesn't
have the perfect gravels it's authentic so Chris
I actually it's incredibly dirty falcony's been
having trouble laundering his cash for some time
oh damn let him go because he's with
me also because he's the D.A who put
all your friends into Arkham we got room for
one more yeah of course you do Falcone owns
the mayor and the entire city assembly so
the only way to make an impact is to make
it disappear moving it could take days burn
it well who said anything about moving it
why are you trying to hurt Falcone
well why are you it's not personal
sweetheart it's Justice it can be personal
assistant yes heads we burn it down okay
[Music]
oh the cut oh no oh fantastic
Batman shops at magic stores
oh man got a huge break tonight on this
Falcone Thing Once I take him out we can
start a family you know I can't we'll talk
about options when you're ready but no are we
still having movie night or not yeah what'd
you pick take off your Mia Wallace costume
oh no oh I knew and I was still shocked
I completely forgot damn paste it just
well enough that I was like
oh look how cute [Applause]
great Batmobile Taki is roasting
the pies are cooling and Kyle is on
make a note to order a new windshield
bulletproof it wasn't bulletproof to
begin with I don't know how that went over the
hell you think this is come on this is Gotham
oh this is Chinatown yeah
ever seen that have you ever seen Chinatown
that like Jack uh I've tried Nicholson movie
I've tried to watch it a few times okay I
quote it but I've never seen it yeah this
is Chinatown I don't know what that means
yet you will someday someday oh dope shot
Batman movies need more chinatowns
oh
you thought wrong ah we buddies
were seen outside Harvey Dent's
house on Halloween we were trick-or-treating
show me your candy having fun
not yet but any second now no
no damn
yeah Big Trouble in Little Chinatown
damn
[Laughter] nicely done
like the martial arts in this yeah
damn
don't tase me bro Beast of a dude hey was it good
keep an eye on your little friends a thank
you would be nice thank you we can make this
easy Mickey just tell me who hired them to kill
Dent go the hell the only difference between you
and me is that I know what's down here there's a
Killer Croc looking in these sewers straight line
dough there he is Grundy my man there he
is born on a Monday this is your place
give them to me and I'll make sure
he never sets a book down here again
take him good I got my Cameo
for the day there it is you guy
yes where were you on Halloween you're late
it's fine it's good he's thankful he's more of a
holiday man he gets into the season oh this one's
done for your husband it's for you from um Mr
Falcone I'm sorry ma'am it's none of my business
isn't it time for his dinner it's not my business
what the hell are you doing tied up with gangsters
also how does she not a scratch on her she was in
that fire I know I just holding a man I don't even
know come on Falcone the Roman contracted your
Triad to take out Harvey Dent your signatures all
over it you gotta help me keep my friend here calm
good cop bad cop Batman good cop bad cop Jazz
are for suspects this guy's Anderson oh geez I
want to do that to somebody that's great
we have a lot to be thankful for Alberto
Health family what's left of it if you
are referring to your cousin Johnny that
is being handled by Mickey Chen and who do
you think hired him I love the sound effects
this is such a good job gaffing this is there
something you wish to say except to point out
that Harvey Dent is still alive is
that Jack Quaid because I allow it
the dangers of independent thought sounds like
Jack yeah that sounds like Titus Welliver when
have you had one independent thought maybe
when I sent flowers to dense hospital room
in the Falcone name you did what Oh I
thought it would take suspicion off of
us if we look like we care about his recovery
now I suppose you'll say it was a sloppy move
why did you send them in that name two for two
excellent work any notion you may hold about
being next in line to take over our business
interests is a pathetic delusion yeah [Music]
I'm on my way home for Thanksgiving dinner
you should come along Barbara always makes
a ton I'm not hungry flip a coin what are we
doing here maybe I wasn't ready for this yet
I think I'm gonna go back now don't you
worry about Harvey um already worried
when a guy acts like that you hand him
a gun yeah the falconies are dangerous
people and to them you're the bad
guy protect your family protect
your girl who's clearly been off
this whole time [Laughter] [Music]
that nip
oh Batman giving Grundy some turkey
a little Thanksgiving for Solomon
thank you shocks Batman
Gordon laughed
foreign
[Music] work on that one close up meanwhile at
the top of Mount Crumpet the Grinch continued
plotting his heart would not grow three sizes that
day I should be out hunting we've got it covered
all of Gotham PD will be deployed throughout
town by midnight oh and when he said hunting he
meant like on Supernatural when holiday comes
calling touch we'll be ready you know this is
all you I wanted them and Gotham Penitentiary
oh my God that is a different looking Jonathan
Charlie Day oh but this court thing on Hard Times
mapping things in calendar man who killed
Johnny VD on Halloween vidi was the Roman's
nephew the Roman was Chen's employer
first suspect is therefore the Roman
I told you to bring Mr Dent he isn't safe out
there the TA who put you all in Arkham half the
patients here would kill him on site so I'd
say out there is the only place he is safe
six of one half a dozen of the other or perhaps
he doesn't know you're here perhaps the district
attorney is a suspect um love his voice there's
lots of crazy out there these days and just when
you thought you'd cleaned it all up oh what
a joke oh no why did you make that reference
no it's too easy too easy unknown yes
whoa [Laughter]
he had somebody get to my kid if I didn't help him
I'm sorry oh buddy outside it
suits awful chiller [Laughter]
good rendition
oh there's that art
looking for this Put the gun down and we'll talk
oh geez just shot a point blank in the nuts almost
bullets or keep count oh
wow
where did you get that why you missing one
D.A Dent is more than he appears to be I'll
make sure little Gilda doesn't have to close
shop a hubby wubby ever again you call that
a joke but you but you haven't even heard
the punchline it goes like this ah it's
not your best material Joker it worked
for me I'll take a good punchline all right
any idea where he was heading Moroni Manja
no that's snowpack
[Music]
what happened to your friend's face Maroney
nothing what happened to yours [Music]
he was inside before we got there took out
the whole staff poisoned the fajol I wasn't
hungry but uh Freddy here not the forzole
he put a gun in my face and told me that
this is his Turf and that he's cracking down
on interlopes freaks used to play Way Out On
The Fringe but once you showed up yeah relax
pal yeah now we got killer Crocs and moths
and Sewer zombies yeah a homicidal maniac
sculpting around the holidays it made men
what's the common thread where is he but
if he's the guy killing Falcone's men it's
only a matter of time till he gets to
Old Carmine himself maybe start there
yeah just Shadow Carmine the whole night
easy sleep with two eyes oh what my pet gun
hello what the hat if you're
gonna kill me just do it
do it face of a killer
if you hear any news about the holiday
investigation I'd like you to pass it my way
heart [Laughter] the hell
looks like a good time boys [Music]
kiss him it's the rules
no dang Jesus hand Cannon God that is
like a giant gun well that was good
this is such a rascal in this movie
[Music]
still smoking
oh the snow globe [Music] I love how they're
doing these yeah Johnny Beauty was about to
flip and Mickey Chen could testify that
Falconi ordered dense murder but why kill
his own bodyguard may I ask why you're
keeping the fifth suspect off the board
for the twist I'm blacked it out myself
obsessed with taking down Falcone he was
turned down for a gun license last year when
the psyche vow showed some wild aberrations
here it is or is it someone else entirely I
thought this would be about sweeping criminals
off the street I never thought the Batman
was going to have to be a detective [Music]
I really overestimated this Batman will
be what the world needs him to be or what
the world deserves the same I believe should
be said of Bruce Wayne has a great shot yeah
you're putting on yeah I would like to thank our
corporate sponsors cord on reversal soda polar
and for the 10th year run Gotham Broadcasting
Company uh great name drops Court boom I have it
thank you to steal that broach one more thing we
believe in family we believe in Gotham City the
sun I never had oh no Mr Bruce Wayne oh Christ
no no no no oh dude he's freaking right there
I mean of course but but wow great setup of
that speech dead pilot check Brown crew check
it's time to ring in the New Year passing
your seat belts as I have no idea how
hey yep I would expect no less I feel like I feel
like whatever this is whatever we've tried to be
to one another is unraveling we've never spoken
of it but the truth is that you and I are two
different people one of us has herpes now we both
I don't think we're ever going to be able to put
it all together come on the bat in the cat I guess
we're just not cut out come on whatever this is oh
did she know how many levels is this conversation
taking place when did you do it you took my watch
I'm curious take it from me Bruce around here
curiosity can get you killed oh and you would know
[Music]
spray
to fly by didn't load it well
pretty yes the green Baron get
out of there everyone yeah you've
got a chance like so just assume
that he's not gonna do anything
oh [__] what are you trying
to prove with this stunt Joker
true stunt Joker no wait that one's right
you think I'm holiday I didn't know you cared
oh yep yep yep the boutonniere if I were him
why would I be trying to kill him he's the
competition I won't be number two [Music]
oh wow it took me a second well I guess everyone
in Gotham Square half the cities down there
which means holiday either is or isn't and
if I fail well at least I've killed a lot of
innocent people yep Silver Lining no don't kill
me not before I find out who holiday is why do
you care I'm just like you we both love a good
puzzle we're both the world's greatest detective
uh yeah to do it
[Music]
gotta contaminate all the fish in Gotham yes
it's like please don't crash into a boat I'm an
Oxford graduate who's learned more about business
than my father could ever hope to understand
you don't get a seat at the table because I'm
weak I fell in love how is that weak cause Love's
for Susie's yeah what happened to her I let him
scare her away from me why do I
feel like I can talk to you I I just
no yes let's do this oh no no I'm sorry oh
get away from her you [__] Bruce wait oh
dude no Wayne no what Wayne is is this the
Batman Selena Alberto Falcone is holiday
what did you just do I don't want control
of the family I never did I would happily
trade that for a normal life to get married
and have a child with you that was so clever
okay yeah he did get shot I was like
I had firework timing was magic oh
where okay there you could know
you're missing so many pieces oh
oh
damn that is that's a hell of a way to go
oh whoa [Music]
it's the criminal on all the neighborhood watch
signs have you seen this man he's killed everyone
he's responsible for all crime
she thinking for Old Lang Syne boy old
acquaintances be forget whenever they're
gonna split this as a part one part two now
I'm curious hell of a way to go that isn't
how we went he was shot by holiday before going
overboard Alberta wasn't holiday it was Occam's
razor Jim the simplest solution this is your
fault [Music] Alberto Falcone wasn't holiday
then who is that's not important right now
and who's next we got till Valentine's Day yes
oh dang so wait a minute then
is she would she have recorded the second
movie by then I don't know wow damn
and two like this this very much feels like a
chapter break like you have just a very sort of
graceful yeah you know coming to a I was just
thinking like where is it gonna are they gonna
escalate into the next holiday and like I remember
the comic always had that feeling between books
uh David does small stream was uh calendar man
that's the voice yeah of course terrified of
course his sort of like seething eeriness
yeah pitchy uncomfortable I can definitely
it's incredible because he's like one of the
nice people in the world that he's just so
good at being terrifying well I feel like that's
yeah that's like a common sense yeah it's like
people who who play the most sort of like uh
either you know maniacal or or just Eerie off
just more often yeah the like sweetest most
empathetic people but I guess you have to be
to to put yourself in the darkness the less than
glamorous shoes perhaps you know man that was good
yeah I really like that a lot like I love the
mood and I love the pace like we you know after
watching so many of these and and contrasting and
comparing the DC AMU stuff we've seen to the you
know brief excursions outside the dcamu I feel
like this still uniquely you know has its own
very patient tone and Pace that I appreciate
this and the Frank Miller two-parter I'm really
really value with because this felt a lot like
long Halloween without trying a lot like I said
about the ring Miller one it's adapting without
trying so directly to become it but even the
Frank Miller one like the things we loved the
pauses the taking the shot like those things
they did and that I love that this just felt
like the the world built like it didn't try
to be Tim sales art because again I don't know
if it would have translated but instead like
there was a shot of Batman where it's like
him hunt shoulder and he's looking sideways
and they grabbed like the lighting of his cape
that looked just like Tim sale in little moments
like that for me really beautifully grabbed the
world and obviously the writing's very Jeff Loeb
um but man that was incredible 2021 yeah
this is new well and and yeah like there's
little flourishes like the Joker uh like his
design his his like fangly Teeth oh oh [Music]
man amen color mine if there's anything you
know what I want you to do but time and time
again you refuse me when are we going for
golf the Wayne Foundation isn't a money
laundering outfit for the mom of course I don't
believe you've met my associate Charmed damn it
no
cool post credit very cool yeah like we'll go
back to the uh the cast list because like this
this was stacked uh yeah Not only was the cast
incredible but like I really do appreciate the
pacing I really appreciate how much it loved the
source material but it's also like such a good
movie like I feel like this is just like if you
don't even like Comics there's a lot going on here
oh yeah 100 and I mean yeah it's got so much again
cinematic flourish and it's got these like new
Irish elements like yeah it very much feels like
what I remember about the art and the mood of that
book and and it's pretty long like it's a thick
book and yeah and you really do feel like the
feel like it really puts you in even though you're
hopping from holiday to Holiday you still feel
like you're sort of living in the space between
it still feels like a long year you know right
as this goes and and I feel like they've managed
to while still you know keeping it you know in an
hour and 25 minute package or whatever still like
clipping along nicely enough but also yeah with
that same sense of breath between everything dread
like one of the favorite things about the book is
that you're like you said a long year it does feel
like they're being uh beaten down by the time like
the time is another villain of this because they
like there's a they know a holiday is coming they
know they failed here they know another holiday
is coming like it's the lack of control in in
this story that they have that like doesn't work
if you rush it yeah because you don't feel the
dread of another holiday you don't feel the dread
of failure you don't feel like grind yeah and I
really think they captured that here especially
with like this is only Halloween to New Year's
yeah I know right we still got like a whole
big old leg of the journey to go yeah and and
like you know the each time you know they give at
least a little bit of service to the idea of what
everyone's doing for the holiday like you know I
like this story what I remember about the story
partly because like yeah I think it's a really
wonderful Motif it's a great serial killer motif
so just a great aesthetic Motif so you constantly
have Gotham under these different coats of decorum
and yeah yeah yeah and so uh I don't know yeah
it's really kind of just yeah kind of capturing
and highlighting and accentuating the unique
sort of fun of this particular story and I I
think I've read this about five years ago not
quite as long as Dark Knight but uh it's just
like a long time since I've read this yeah it's
just it's one of the classics like this is a book
I recommend to everybody always like oh yeah also
I was completely wrong that wasn't Mark Hamill
that was Troy Baker dude I was I was wondering
that during the reaction because the times we've
heard Troy Baker do Joker it is the one that is
like he's so close to Mark Hamilton is almost in
like I want to go now and figure out what the
yeah I know but that's the thing is like now
I want to figure out what's the specific earmark
where you can tell when it's which one versus uh
uh yeah Mark Hamill because I feel like whenever
they they have Troy Baker do Joker it seems like
the point that they're going for is to emulate
Mark Hamill yeah because it's so spotless like
it's so that that it doesn't seem like it's trying
to be anything other than that yeah so yeah so I
wonder I I'd like the Tells it seem like they
would have to be kind of subtle because I feel
like he mainly worked with Kevin Conroy so I was
surprised that you know this was a Jensen Ackles
Batman I said mainly I'm sure there's examples but
like I was like is this the last time he played
Joker because this is so recent but yeah Troy
Baker crushed it I [__] love that performance
that was so Sensational yeah no 100 and like I
love the the role The Joker plays in this might
be my favorite Joker it could be yeah yeah like
that you asking the Phantasm like those are my
favorite like portrayals and animation like these
were solid like the jokes were great the Mania was
great the delivery was great I also loved Billy
Burke as Commissioner Gordon yeah good old uh
Papa Twilight oh my God is that who that is I'm
90 sure it's not Billy Burke right isn't that like
that's who I think it is
God yes he is oh good call yeah that's such
a Billy Burke guy that's so good he's great
he's killing it Josh Jamel is uh Harvey Dent there
yeah did not hear that one did not did not place
it and that's good because because his design his
character design reminds me so much of Archer and
when he speaks uh he you know doesn't so like
that's good it helps to kind of separate from
that uh but yeah I think he's doing a great job
and Naya Rivera like rest in peace but I I like
her like I'm sad now the prospect of more Catwoman
portrayals from her won't you know be on the table
because uh because I really like their back and
forth and I I love that interlude of them chasing
each other on the rooftops and how yeah it's so
flirty it's so flirty but it's also like it's
very again atmospheric and they're not talking a
lot it's sort of just a visual moment it's almost
a silent moment that is prolonged you know for
the course of like an entire scene and uh yeah
I like that I think is a great great aspect of
I you know a beloved novel like this deserves
or or uh The Dark Knight Returns like things like
that you know you deserve a two-parter but it's
also you know you see why uh that's such a good
idea when you have or I don't know you just see
how much that benefits it when you get moments
like that that are allowed to breathe that way I
really love the sound design uh in every sequence
that sequence is one of the first times I noticed
it especially but like the use of the rain the
use of like certain um no yeah there's just so
many sound moments in this because it's so calm
and ponderous and and that's the book the book
is very pensive and there's a lot of frames that
are just art and that's that's kind of what we
were saying earlier with the uh the Tim sale
art maybe not just directly going to animation
because so many frames are just like oomph still
and silence and they managed to capture that
without replicating the art yeah yeah and still
while having a striking artistic palette I mean
so many great beautiful just Gotham Skyline shots
and the way they have this sky and the moon and
all these different things and I don't know yeah
this is really really it's a modern production
certainly and there are elements of the animation
that feel very modern however they do have some of
those flourishes that feel like yeah here's a big
watercolor backdrop or something giant yacht shot
yeah the background watercolor Sky you know is
always a great impact moment in this Jen snackles
Crush too I'm uh even more excited about uh the
prospect of him playing live action one I would
love like you know we've heard him now as red
hood and we've heard now is Bruce Wayne we'll
see him again in the next installment but uh yeah
I'm loving his portrayal so far I mean he's the
right age I play him in real life that's true I'm
just saying and I know James Gunn like I mean the
the David Corn sweat and Rachel Bosnian casting is
very much like Twitter being like these people so
uh do your job again Twitter and uh let's get some
Jensen Ackles Batman absolutely and it was it was
Jack Quaid as Alberto it was for him older like
my brain was like uh Jack was young like I I like
kept seeing the wrinkles on a blurred to the face
and I was like is it him yeah that and that was
like a great performance by Jack quick because it
didn't sound young it sounded like that like there
was a lot of little extra like edges to words and
stuff it was good work yeah and yeah he sounds
very weathered by just life what the character has
had to go through what he sums up there uh towards
the towards the end yeah before he's murdered
and I love this yeah I mean it's it's it's of
this movie it's also of the the book but yeah the
way you have so many of Gotham's different Rogues
being like I want to find out who this holiday is
too you know what's going on it could easily be
me but it's not me like I could have taken my job
yeah yeah yeah and having like to go and consult
and that's like a well-worn Batman thing too is
like going to Arkham and Gathering it yeah talk
to someone from prison yeah but like I love just
the way that this particular Story presents that
and yeah you're jumping around to all these people
who would like love to take credit but won't yeah
and I love how often like you've seen this story
adapted in different ways uh I recently did a what
to read if you like this video and for the Batman
I recommended long Halloween because there's a lot
of slow ponderous it's very Jeff Lowe Tim's
sale there's holidays in it like that movie
is very much that but then also The Dark Knight
the other most iconic Batman movie I would argue
uh sorry Michael Keaton as well but like the most
recent other of the big iconic uh obviously the a
lot of the stories is like the three of them
Harvey and Gordon and Batman the giant stack
of money there's Falcone like there's a lot but
I would say the dark tonight and the Batman are
so different totally they're connecting to this
right I mean yeah there's so much Rich story in
the long Halloween that you can adapt The Dark
Knight and you can adapt the Batman you can have
a Nolan action movie Heist uh the Heat and you can
also have not the heat but heat and you can also
have the Batman which is you know your your David
Fincher your seven you're and that's how strong
and Rich the story is yeah well that's what two
is is so lovely I think about comics in particular
is that you whereas like with a novel or a book
or something that is it's one kind of thing it's
like yes this is one particular story and this
is the direct adaptation of that but yeah you
can look at multiple other adaptations and go oh
this piece of work the long Halloween especially
keeps popping up in these aspects and details
and yeah the way you can make things that feel
so different while clearly also drawing direct
inspiration from the same Touchstone and we've
still never had a beautiful this movie we've still
never had a long Halloween and we've had the two
biggest adaptations of recent history not do this
but do this because it is so rich yeah so yeah I
love this as my top third uh it's gonna be really
hard when we rank all of them because uh I think I
think everything is in the top there everything's
well there's a couple that are there's a couple
it's basically low downers top third and then a
couple yes it's gonna be a real issue yeah that's
not how math works but uh we're gonna be ranking
those or by the time you've seen this we may have
already that is on the books we got some stuff
cooking but that when we rank our first video just
going to be the DC AMU this will not be included
we are going to do this all when we've seen them
all which could be a couple years but uh we'll see
you very soon for that DC AMU we got a patreon I
want to get some love Tunes give some love to
a patron right who do we got this very video
Mikhail Lyndon McHale listen up this is a very
elegant Gotham story all right and I can just
imagine you you know sitting around the Falcone
you know table there breaking bread with everybody
made Man part of the family but conflicted it's
the holidays you got a family of your own to think
about how did you fall into this life can you take
credit for the dastardly Deeds of foot nay but you
could do something to stop them Mikhail because
you're an upstanding citizen of the Gotham that
is patreon all right so uh Hey keep it real
and uh stay elegant out there but maybe put
your unique and innate skills to a more benevolent
purpose you know as we've left this movie off it's
Christmas it's New Year it's time to turn over
New Leaf Mikhail so while you would make I think
a perfect mobster I also think that you're moral
compass is greater than a few dirty dollars if you
know what I mean family oh like the fast family
not the mob family use your elegant crime tactics
to save people Boogie Michaela Linden great
name I like that name yeah it's a great name
yeah there's so many great comic book characters
both the first and last name separate and together
excellent work excellent there's a little accent
a little like Santa goo over the e in there does
that mean is it Linden kale Linden sort of like
someone you go to for like advice advice or like
a wise some yeah some like real yeah it's either
like Sage advice or some kind of like ancient
knowledge that is hitherto lost to man except
for by Michael Linden yeah we appreciate you
thank you all right that's gonna do what you
lovelies we are gonna wrap on Audi here we'll be
back for the long Halloween part yeah most likely
next week and that is very exciting stuff because
this first one was excellent again do not envy uh
us ranking them all but they're it's coming it's
it's coming one day uh please let us know in the
comments what you want us to watch after the long
Halloween part yeah and uh please don't yell at
me for calling him Mark Hamill it sounded a lot
like him I do apologize to everyone retroactively
I mean the people have already written it they've
already been yelling it's already in all caps
and I'm sorry now I hope you get to this part
of the video and go man I shouldn't have yelled
in all caps I could have just said like no call
you fool it's Troy Baker and I still would
feel bad about it but here we are here we
are all right you love you remember check out
the bat first shirt remember Comic-Con Saturday
early afternoon and remember call your family
tell them you love them whether they're a mob
family or a fast family they're worth your love
we'll talk to you soon happy Halloween let's see